voilà ce qu'il reste de la remorque et
de la cargaison d'un chauffeur poids
lourd qui arrivait du mans une carcasse
détruites calciné en bordure de rond
point à la sortie 27 de l'autoroute a28
la sortie de neuillé-pont-pierre
lincendie de ce camion vers 5 heures du
matin a provoqué la fermeture de la
sortie d'autoroute une bonne partie de
la matinée ainsi que de la route
départementale 766 très fréquentée par
les poids lourds
le feu a commencé par un pneu crevé sur
l'autoroute les cieux a sans doute
frotter s'est enflammé et comme le poids
lourd transportait des palettes et des
matières inflammables à combustion
toxiques type bisphénol a les pompiers
n'ont pu que ralentir lincendie le
chauffeur plein de sang froid a pris le
temps de décrocher la remorque et mettre
le tracteur et la cabine hors de portée
des flammes sur le rond point
le chauffeur poids lourd a eu le bon
réflexe il a remarqué effectivement un
problème au niveau de sa remorque au
niveau des pneumatiques et l'a décidé de
sortir et c'était un bon réflexe parce
que sur l'autoroute il y aurait eu des
conséquences plus importante eu égard
aux feux de circulation
en ce lundi matin la route
départementale a été rouverte vers 10h30
tout comme la sortie de l'autoroute
en revanche l'accès à la 28 n'a été
possible qu'en début d'après midi